the Department of Homeland Security
warns that the migrant caravan at the
San Diego border contains over 500 known
criminals prompting Tijuana residents to
protest what they are calling an
invasion then video killed the TV star
Trump beats the White House
Correspondents Association and Mohammed
celebrates his 1440 seventh birthday
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Department of Homeland I'm sorry I'm
getting breaking news in here I'm sorry
just one second yes we can now confirm
the Daily wire can confirm Donald Trump
has pardoned the Thanksgiving turkey we
cut now to a live shot from the White
House in this grand tradition I am
pleased to announce that today's lucky
bird and guest of honor is named two
peas along with his alternate named
carrots the children will understand
that the winner of this vote was decided
by a fair and open election conducted on
the White House website this was a fair
election unfortunately carrots refused
to concede and demanded a recount and
we're still fighting with carrots and I
will tell you we've come to a conclusion
carrots I'm sorry to tell you the result
did not change it's too bad for carrots
too bad for carrots too bad for Stacey
Abrams in Georgia too bad for and her
Gilliam in Florida I love him so much I
love when Trump does this he's at his
best he's funny and he's not missing any
opportunity to just get a little dig in
there at the left a little dig at these
Democrats who won't give up elections
even at the turkey pardon one of the
stupidest most frivolous traditions in
the presidency he takes the opportunity
to just get a great zinger in there at
the left really great stuff we have a
lot to talk about but first let's make a
little money with a ring you know ring
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer today over a million people use
the amazing ring video doorbell to help
protect their homes you know them
because it's all your cool friends all
you know when you go to that you have
some people have friends were cool some
are you know aren't that cool you go to
your cool friends house and they have
that cool ring video doorbell there they
have the floodlight camera so you've got
you can see people and you can see when
things go bump in the night all of rings
stuff is it's so accessible because with
the ring video doorbell you can see
people who are there you can talk to
them whether you're inside the house
whether you're at work whether you're in
our beach in Boca it's HD video two-way
audio lets you know the moment anyone
steps onto your property you can even
set off an alarm
right from your phone whether you're
home or away the ring floodlight camera
lets you keep an eye on your home from
anywhere a ring floodlight offers the
ultimate in home security with high
visibility flood lights and a powerful
HD camera that puts security in your
hands the nice thing is it's uploaded to
the cloud so even if the thief steals
your ring it doesn't matter you'll have
it you can send it to your neighbors
save up to 150 bucks off a ring of
security kit when you go to ring DICOM /
knowles kenda wles ring.com / knowles
kenda wles what is it ring calm /
knowles
so according to the department of
homeland security in news that does not
relate to weather peas or carrots or
whichever turkey is being pardoned by
the president when you look to our
southern border the department of
homeland security is now saying but that
caravan which has been moving from
honduras through Guatemala to Mexico now
to the u.s. southern border now has
about 500 known criminals in it these
are people who are wanted for aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon armed
robbery sexual assault and child assault
on a female we're not talking about
somebody stealing a Snickers bar from
the newspaper stand we're talking about
dangerous criminals about 500 of them
right now I think it's about 7,000
people it's expected to swell again to
10,000 people so again obviously it's
not the majority of these people are
violent criminals but it's not an
insignificant portion either when you're
talking about 500 people out of 5,000
7,000 that's that's a pretty significant
chunk obviously the left doesn't want to
admit this they want to say that it's
perfectly normal for people to cross
national borders illegally to just
wander around other other countries
without any right to do so they want to
pretend that that's normal and they want
to pretend that Americans are wrong and
evil for saying no thank you we have a
border you have to follow our laws one
issue right now that the left has to
deal with is that citizens of other
countries are admitting that this is
insane
because you got to remember these these
migrants are coming from Honduras they
go all the way up now they're in Mexico
the Mexicans aren't any happier about
this than the United States is they've
now got 10,000 people wandering around
their country causing mayhem in the
streets so there was a group of
protesters Mexican national protestors
in
tijuana here's what they were chanting
just the other day for those who don't
speak Spanish I don't speak Spanish
either but I could at least make that
out he's saying this is an invasion I am
saying Donald Trump was right this is an
invasion of course it's an invasion if
this isn't an invasion then what is an
invasion what's the definition of an
invasion it's when another group comes
into your territory in a hostile manner
and does whatever they want regardless
of laws regardless of the demands of the
people who are in that territory so this
is obviously happening the tijuana mayor
one man well gasps Tulum is calling
these people bums and bums is what they
are they're they're breaking laws
they're not just breaking the laws of
the United States or trying to they're
breaking the laws of Mexico they're
breaking the laws of other countries
along that route what the left is trying
to pretend now is that it's all women
and children that's what they always
said women and children coming through
they're just looking for a better life
they're fleeing violence it isn't the
best estimates we have or that of the
7,000 people there maybe a thousand of
them or women and children the rest
6,000 or so or young men no surprise
this happened in 2015 when a Muslim
migrants from Syria from Afghanistan
from other places in the Middle East
when they flooded into Europe we were
all told it was women and children it
was refugees and yet all virtually all
of these people were young unvetted
single men and that that's what we're
seeing here now the Department of
Homeland Security is also warning quote
citizens of countries outside of Central
America including countries in the
Middle East Africa South Asia and
elsewhere are currently traveling toward
through Mexico toward the US so again
not a spontaneous uprising we never
believed that it was but this shows you
the national security threat they just
arrested a number of Bangladeshi
nationals who were found to have made it
into Mexico we're trying to get up into
the united states people from all over
the world why wouldn't they
the president of guatemala said that
he's deported
a number of Isis related Islamic
terrorists who made it into his country
some of us think that's far-fetched
because we don't expect to see Islamic
terrorists on the other side of the
globe in Central America but if the plan
here is to damage the United States to
invade the United States why wouldn't
they go to Mexico why wouldn't they go
to Guatemala or Honduras or El Salvador
or other failed States that can allow
them to slip in and slip up into the
United States especially when half of
the United States is encouraging the
invasion is saying that if you oppose
the invasion that you're somehow racist
or bigoted or hateful or whatever on top
of all of this a judge has ruled that
President Trump cannot turn away illegal
immigrants who have crossed at places
that are not official ports of entry so
what we've got now because the United
States is so generous in its in its
immigration policy if you show up to a
port of entry and you have you got no
papers you're not vetted you're not
being offered citizenship you're not
being offered immigration and you just
say I'm here to be a refugee they'll
process you they'll bring you through
refugee proceedings and see if you can
be granted political asylum now some
people don't want to wait in line some
people don't want to wait that long so
they'll cross over illegally between
ports of entry if they're then arrested
by immigration and customs enforcement
President Trump was saying they've
forfeited their right to be granted
asylum they're already breaking our laws
we've got to kick them out this federal
judge John Tiger is saying absolutely
not even those people have to be
processed even people that we are
catching in a crime their first act in
the United States is a crime even they
will be processed and possibly given
asylum
so this strikes down or at least halts
president Trump's executive order his
recent executive order to to get those
people out of the country the left is
claiming that Donald Trump is
anti-immigrant that he's isolationist
that Republicans or is xenophobic that
we want to kick people out of the
country where do you see this show me
the specific example president Trump
himself has said we want immigrants we
just want them to come legally but show
me the example where is this happening
we can't stop immigrants between ports
of entry
we're now is seeing two thousand pee
per day illegally flooding into this
country even with the United States
military we've sent the military to the
border even then we can't enforce our
laws where where is this isolationist
cruel United States what it seems to me
is that we're impotent we're not able to
enforce our basic laws were being held
back at every turn
by creative interpretations of
immigration law by half of the country
the radical left which wants open
borders and by judges who are insisting
that we can't even enforce laws that are
on the books so open border seems to be
the only op the that's the only option
that the left is willing to give us we
have to remind ourselves no nation on
earth has open borders no nation with
open borders has ever remained a nation
very long it's insane
why would we tolerate this Mexico won't
tolerate this there are protests in the
streets in Mexico why show me the
example of the United States being
especially cruel to immigrants from all
I can see the United States is the most
generous country in the world when it
comes to an immigration regime the left
can't show an example so they just talk
in these slogans nobody is illegal
they're dreamers you they use all of
these various euphemisms undocumented
future Americans undocumented dreamers
whatever it's all slogans ask them to
cite you a specific example of the
United States having a cruel immigration
policy they say well the reason that
people are entering illegally is because
our immigration regime is too
restrictive we right now in the United
States have something like 19% of the
population foreign-born this is the
highest number since the 1890s what
number would you prefer if if 19 or 20
percent of the population being
foreign-born is too low what would you
prefer for 30 percent 40 percent 60
percent at what point is when is your so
much of your country foreign-born that
the country itself no longer has a claim
to its own identity I'm not suggesting
that we should cut off all immigration
but especially especially at a time when
half of the country is saying we can't
assimilate anybody
we shouldn't assimilate anybody they
should Maine
their exact same culture in their exact
same language and not change a single
thing to come to America at what point
do you not have a country anymore what
other countries on earth have 20%
foreign-born populations 19% I don't see
a lot of them you've got to drill down
to the specifics and they'll fall silent
because all they have are slogans
speaking of falling silent one of my
favorite things to do every single days
when I come home from this from this
show I you know obviously I've been
working at that point for already three
or maybe even four hours and so I'm
really exhausted and I like to just lie
down on my purple mattress you know how
much I love my purple mattress I'm a
proselytize er for my purple mattress it
is the greatest mattress ever period
that's all it is it's not an innerspring
it's not exactly a memory foam it is
this new technology developed by rocket
scientists I have no idea what it is I
couldn't tell you it's kind of squishy
it's kind of firm it feels the mattress
feels both firm and soft at the same
time I know that doesn't sound like it
means anything just try it you'll
believe me it's the greatest I've never
slept better my back feels great and
I've got back problems in my family it's
absolutely fabulous it will feel
different than anything you've ever
experienced it's just this new material
it's unique
it's also sleeps very cool which is
really really nice you can get a 100
night risk-free trial if you're not
fully satisfied return your mattress for
a full refund you will not return it
it's backed by 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns free in-home setup
old mattress removal it's at do it I'm
telling you you spend money on the
things that matter which is where you
spend some people spend a third of their
life on their bed
I spend obviously more like four-fifths
it really matters you're gonna love
purple my listeners get a free purple
pillow with purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to great free gifts
are all free site-wide text cough fa c
OV e fe fe - 47 47 47 that's the only
way to get a free pillow text cough fac
OVF e fe - 47 47 47 that is CoV fe fe 47
47 47 get that cool mattress so drill
into the specifics that's where they
will fall silent nobody has shown this
better in recent days than Dan Crenshaw
you know Dan Crenshaw
he's the war hero who's injured he's he
was just elected to Congress he wears an
eyepatch and SNL made fun of him so Dan
Crenshaw was on Face the Nation and this
whole left-wing cabal on Face the Nation
they were
about how Donald Trump is ruining
democracy threatening democracy
threatening our freedoms we've heard
this we see this in the Washington Post
in The New York Times on CNN at the
coffee cooler well do we have coffee
coolers note we have coffee machines and
water coolers we hear that we're gonna
hear this at our Thanksgiving table with
our left-wing in-laws and Dan Crenshaw
asks a very simple question show me an
example
I mean precisely that that I think some
of our democratic freedoms and the
principles that we live by I have been
under attack for the better part of the
last two years
congressman Locke do you want to respond
to that since the president has is the
leader of your party why I always ask
the question like like what you know
like what is he undermining exactly you
know what what democratic freedoms have
been undermined we just had an election
where we switched switched power in the
house democracy is at work people are
voting and in record numbers
I always asked for example and then we
can hit those examples one by one and if
it's and if it's worth criticizing it's
worth criticizing but just kind of this
broad brush criticism that the president
is somehow undermining our democracy I
always wonder that what exactly we're
talking about I love that approach
because this guy this is a pretty tough
hombre obviously you can see the patch
on his eye this is a warrior this is a
fighter but when he presents himself in
front of left wingers and in front of
the public
he is so reasonable he just he kind of
sits back he says well what are you
talking about this is what whenever you
see right-wingers in those videos on the
internet you know so-and-so destroys
so-and-so usually it's not because the
guy is yelling at whatever stupid
college kid it is it's because he he
allows his adversary to tie the noose
around his own neck rhetorically
speaking he allows his adversary to
stumble and expose the shallowness of
his ideas it's not usually a slam dunk
it's a question you say I think there
was one of Ben Wright he said how many
genders are there maybe it was bad I
forget he said something about gender
everybody asks the question and this is
a good example there was someone on
Twitter the other day tweeted out there
are more than two genders this is just a
fact you asked them how many are there
you give me the number you tell me and
we'll talk about it they fall silent
that's what he says he says what what
freedoms are being limited
they jump in one guy says well freedom
of the press it's a freedom of why
because Jim Acosta was kicked out of a
press room
CNN didn't lose its press credentials
CNN has other reporters in there Jim
Acosta was disrupting the press
conference he was taking up a lot of
time from other reporters who could ask
questions he was challenging the
president he wasn't asking any questions
he wasn't asking challenging questions
he was debating him he was making
assertions he was stating his own
opinion he was he was being disruptive
so he was kicked out if Donald Trump
were threatening the freedom of the
press he would have thrown CNN out of
there or he would stop having press
conferences this president has been
totally open to the press he's
constantly talking to them they love him
for cuz they get good ratings and he
loves it because he gets to slam them
and make them look like the partisan
hacks that they are how about freedom to
vote we just had a historically high
turnout for a midterm election we never
have high turnout in both parties at
midterm elections usually for the first
midterm after a president is elected
there's high turnout among his
adversaries but there's low turnout
among his own party this time there was
very high turnout about among both sides
people were going out to vote in record
numbers
Democrats were so excited to vote they
voted on Wednesday and Thursday and
Friday I think some of them are still
voting down there in Georgia
how about freedom of Education we've got
the president supporting school choice
supporting charter schools supporting
the ability for students to get out of
bad failing schools that are determined
by their zip code and go to places where
they could succeed and you've got
Democrats like Andrew Gilliam in Florida
was talking about this he said we got to
kill the charter schools we got a kill
school school choice we've just gotta
force kids to go to the failing schools
that their district it into so it seems
on that question of freedom trumping the
Republicans are are far more advanced
than the left
how about freedom of religion you you
had under the Obama administration the
Little Sisters of the Poor suing the
Obama administration because the because
he was trampling over their religious
freedom he was forcing Americans to pay
for abortions he's forcing Americans to
he was forcing Catholic and Christian
employers to pay for abortion inducing
drugs he was trampling over religious
freedom how about under President Trump
none of that an expansion of religious
liberty you're seeing fortunately
finally some of the courts allowing
people to have to practice their
religion to have their own exercise of
conscience to not violate their
religious views not to bake cakes in in
certain designs and participate in in
activities that they find morally
objectionable that's a great expansion
of religious liberty there was just a
Muslim woman elected to the House of
Representatives she wants to wear the
hijab there's a rule against head wear
in chambers of Congress and they're
lifting that for her they're doing it as
a courtesy to her we're seeing an
expansion of religious freedom how about
economic freedom obviously among the
Republicans under Republican governance
there was a great expansion of economic
freedom tax cuts and deregulation your
taxes represent your freedom they're
your money they're the time that you
spend working they're your industry and
when the government takes away your
money they're taking away your time the
the average American if you're paying a
40 percent tax rate then that means
you're working almost half the year for
the federal government your worker will
say you're working five months a year
for the government is their wage slave
you know giving as a vassal as some surf
in their feudal scheme and under
President Trump we're seeing this
greatly expanded all of this talk he's
undermining our freedoms he's
undermining democracy it's lies
it's fake news it's a B s this is a
great strategy from Crenshaw and we
should we should all keep it up because
it cuts the narrative it shows how empty
all of this is the left is so good at
narrative it's why they own the culture
it's why they own Hollywood and the
right is not as good at it because we're
usually so scandalized by the lies that
they're telling us in this narrative but
finally we're taking it back we're
taking it back from the turkey pardon
we're taking it back in little cultural
moments where we can twist and show the
narrative and and we're able to fight
that and expose it
speaking of fake news did you know it's
Muhammad's birthday Mohammed I'm talking
about the seventh century religious
figure from Arabia its Muhammad's
birthday it's his 1440 seventh birthday
and speaking of fake news the New York
Times today ran a doozy
they ran one of the
newest pieces I've seen in the New York
Times in a long time and that is really
saying something they ran a piece called
happy birthday Muhammad now this is an
op-ed piece this was an opinion piece
not a news article
some people have responded to my
criticism of this piece and say well
it's opinion opinions can't be right or
wrong it's just opinion no let me try to
explain this to you postmodern leftists
opinions can be wrong and frequently are
wrong what you're thinking of is a
preference such as I prefer chocolate
ice cream to vanilla ice cream
you're not saying chocolate is
objectively better than vanilla or
sweeter or more delicious or whatever
you're saying you prefer it and a
preference can't be wrong because it's
just your taste it's a subjective
statement of taste an opinion is a
statement of fact as you see it so if I
say I think the leftist tears tumblr is
the greatest and safest vessel for the
transportation of leftist tears that is
a true opinion because it is there is no
greater vessel for this safe
transportation of leftist tears than
this the FDA agrees with me that is a
true opinion if I say I think it is my
opinion that two plus two equals seven
that's a wrong opinion it's but hey man
that's just your opinion right is your
opinion but it's wrong all of that is
prefaced to say it's Muhammad's birthday
this guy Haroon Moghul wrote this
glowing ode to muhammad in the new york
times he gets a few things wrong so he
says what when he Muhammad first
proclaimed prophecy even his own uncle
laughed at him but he never laughed back
his followers were reviled beaten and
killed he didn't strike back if you're
still with me
this is a little bit of a spoiler alert
if you haven't read the Quran he struck
back if Mohammed struck back he was
actually famous for striking back he
struck back all the time you're just a
few verses from the Quran to remind you
of him striking back quote but when the
forbidden months are passed then fight
and slay the pagans wherever you find
them and seize them be Leaguer them and
lie in wait for them strike back
kill them wherever you find them and
drive them out from where they drove you
out strike back when you meet the
unbelievers smite their necks this is a
verse quoted by terrorists who behead
people strike back strike them at the
necks and cut off their fingers that
actually has the word strike in them he
says he never struck back as to those
women from whom you fear disobedience
give them a warning send them to
separate beds and beat them which is to
say strike back hashtag me to strike
back so this is and so this is just in
the Quran did I am just quoting the
Quran how am i quoting the Quran because
when I was a young boy I was thinking
about 14 I read the Quran I read the
Quran before I really seriously read the
Bible not because I was thinking of
converting to Islam but because atheist
leftists in America kept telling me that
Islam was a religion of peace and it was
purely a religion of peace and it never
condoned violence and violence was
against the teachings and practices of
Muhammad and I just sort of suspected
that might not be correct I don't know I
was looking around the world I thought
maybe this isn't the whole story so I
read the Quran and obviously you can
find many many more verses like that but
you don't just have to look for the
Quran you can look to the life of
Muhammad Muhammad was a conqueror
he was a warlord he was a warrior
Muhammad personally led troops in
battles where a thousand people were
killed this is not he he would lead the
slaying of whole tribes of people whole
tribes of people around the Middle East
it is true at various points in his life
especially in the early portion of his
life he talked a very good game on
peacefulness
he did this because he was constantly
under siege at the later periods of his
life
Muhammad dropped a lot of that peace
talk and became much more aggressive in
his personal actions and in his religion
that he created so why on earth would
the New York Times fall for this
nonsense that Muhammad never struck
anybody back he turned the other cheek
is basically what they're saying it's
because of the secular Western impulse
to turn Muhammad into Jesus Christ it's
because of this secular Western impulse
to pretend that Islam is really
Christianity because of the
that defines our civilization is
Christianity and sometime in the modern
era we rejected our religion and we said
that religion is wrong and it's
superstition and it's hocus-pocus and
it's ridiculous and we reacted against
that religion and we made the huge
mistake of believing that all religions
are the same oh really what's the
difference between Christianity and
Islam or non theistic religions like
Buddhism or Hinduism Oh shucks what's
the difference there are major
differences but nobody in the secular
West is going to take those differences
seriously because they don't take
religion seriously we should clear this
up it's a it's a real irony really that
in order to sanitize the history of
Islam for a Western audience what these
left wingers do and left-wing secular
publications like the New York Times do
is they turn Mohammed into Jesus Christ
because I thought that they hated
Christianity they don't like it they
reject Christianity and yet when they're
trying to make a religion look good they
try to make it look like Christianity
but there are major differences here
eben Hussam who is a leading 11th
century Islamic scholar pointed out a
major a fundamental difference between
Christianity and Islam he showed that in
the God of Islam Allah Allah is not even
bound by his own word he's not bound by
his own logic
nothing would oblige him to reveal the
truth to us if it were God's will Allah
if it were a laws will we would even
have to practice idolatry it is a god of
pure will it is a God who is only will
not intellect and will not reason and
will but will this if you want to hear a
good description of this Pope Benedictus
I spoke about it in one of the greatest
I think probably these single greatest
speech of the 21st century the
Regensburg lecture and this difference
is that the God of Islam is a God of
pure will the god of Christianity is a
God of of will and intellect logic and
will it is a God bound by his own logic
a God who is logic itself in the
beginning was the logos and the logos
was with God and the logos was God that
divine logic that is a fundamental
difference the god of Christianity
cannot make you an idolatry and would
not that you would be an idolatry it is
will and intellect and desire altogether
Dante writes about this where the dog
asleep what did shock receive wallet
where where what one can do and what one
wills are exactly united in the heaven
and the god of Christianity that is not
the case in Islam these distinctions
tell you the whole story these
distinctions are why horrific acts can
be committed in the name of Islam with
greater justification with greater
impunity among certain religious circles
why the founding of Islam required the
sword and why that religion was spread
by the sword whereas in the founding of
Christianity it was the early Christians
who were killed by the sword themselves
they were crucified upside down they
were fed to lions and they were maimed
and killed a major distinction exactly
the opposite experience of spreading
that religion the New York Times doesn't
see it I don't know if they're being
obtuse or if they're ignorant probably a
little bit of both the New York Times is
known to be both but we shouldn't fall
for it and the next time that somebody
tells you that the New York Times
doesn't spread fake news point them to
that article I mean really what you
could do is open up any newspaper of the
New York Times and just point to any
random article and you would find it but
this is a keen example of it how an
editor didn't at least question that
ridiculous claim is is beyond me but
it's because probably then the New York
Times just doesn't have very much
dignity anymore okay we've got a lot
more to get to but first today at 5:30
Eastern 2:30 Pacific I will be taking
all of your questions and easing your
anxiety by answering you guys live on
air every query that has burned in your
hearts will be resolved best of all it's
an extra hour-long dose of little old me
who could ask for more than that Elisha
will be there as well that will be
lovely this month's episode will stream
live on Daily wires YouTube and Facebook
pages it will be free for everyone to
watch only subscribers can ask the
questions if you're on daily wire.com
thank you very much you help keep the
lights on here if you're not if you're
on facebook and youtube get over there
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you test questions in the mailbag you
test questions the conversation which is
coming up get your mailbag questions in
for this week by the way tonight or
tomorrow I'm going to do the mailbag
tomorrow because obviously we're all
gonna be out on Thanksgiving so you can
ask me all of your Thanksgiving
questions to make sure you get those in
all that really matters is the leftist
year's tumblr I don't encourage
antagonizing your left-wing relatives at
Thanksgiving I don't think this makes
for a great time
it makes the pumpkin pie taste less
delicious it just is tedious for
everybody now if they bring it up if
they you know don't them not saying back
down or pretend that reality is other
than it is but if something happens if
you know Donald Trump starts pardoning
more turkeys and making fun of more
Democrat gubernatorial candidates and
the leftist tears start flowing you're
not going to want to be at the table
without your leftist ears tumblr you
need it otherwise you'll drown and
there's nothing that I can do to save
you go to daily wire comm we'll be right
back with a lot more
[Music]
speaking of floods that will destroy the
earth Barack Obama's talking about
global warming again remember Barack
Obama he's back I was playing this
earlier someone came into my office they
said who is that who is that guy why is
that guy still talking shouldn't he have
stopped talking a while ago it probably
should have but he didn't he's off on
global warming but then he's using
global warming to attack Donald Trump
because he is a very disrespectful
person here is Barack Obama rambling on
and on and on
the reason we don't do it is because we
are still confused blind shrouded with
hate anger racism mommy issues that's it
that's why that's why we're not raising
carbon taxes that's why we're not
destroying the global economy over over
the Sun Monster that's gonna kill us all
that's why we're not signing on to the
Paris climate agreement even though we
are fulfilling all of the criteria of
the Paris climate agreement and the
signatories to that agreement are
failing to fulfill their their criteria
that's why that's the irony by the way
in his comments we actually are
fulfilling all of these environmental
criteria we actually are fighting the
great menace of global warming in a much
more serious way than any of those pair
of climate countries but he's really
using it to take a shot at brew at
Donald Trump why he says we says we're
not doing anything because we might have
this we might have been he's using we to
mean Donald Trump Donald Trump is the
leader of the country and he's saying
Trump won't fight global warming and why
because of racism because we're filled
with hate and because of mommy issues
Barack Obama does not get to talk about
mommy and daddy issues Barack Obama
wrote an entire self adoring book about
himself called Dreams from My Father
titled after the father that he didn't
know nobody gets to talk about mommy and
daddy issues when you do that Barack but
this is the this is the classic Oh
think it's he pretends to be high-minded
Michelle pretends to be high-minded when
they go low we go high we go high we're
so we're so ethereal we're so we're up
here in the sophisticated area and yet
whenever anybody criticizes them
whenever they don't like what one of
their opponents is doing whenever they
have an honest disagreement and
difference of opinion with somebody they
accused that person of being a racist a
bigot a sexist hateful mean what that's
that's all they do I and obviously he
must be very angry because his entire
legacy has been wiped out by Donald
Trump but he's making himself look even
more shallow than he did as president a
question comes up why be so mean to
Barack Obama he doesn't matter anymore
he's out of it who cares his legacy has
been erased the reason is because these
ideas of his have consequences they they
can lead to a lot of human misery and
you've got to refute them at every
chance you get even even his health care
policy uh pending one-sixth of the
economy depriving people of the doctors
that they liked increasing the cost of
health care for everybody
threatening our freedom when it comes to
health care even that is is a major
threat to the country and we have to
refute these ideas because they're going
to come back Barack Obama's not going
quietly into the sunset to go write some
books and teach a class at U Chicago or
something he is out there he's trying to
remain a player he's trying to undermine
the duly elected president of the United
States
he's calling half the country hateful
awful terrible bigots with mommy issues
and we got to fight back we got to push
him back this is exactly the same with
with ocasion Cortes we have to fight
stupid ideas if you if you miss this
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes is on it again
I actually had a priest right into the
show very nice man who said Michael I
like the show but you're too mean to
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes and you got to
watch it you don't want to seem like
you're being cruel or or unnecessarily
mean you don't want to fall into sin
while you show this left-wing lunacy and
it's a good warning it's a good warning
to keep in mind but it is very important
it is our moral obligation to point out
oh Casio cortezes political idiocy at
every chance we get
she is now I think the youngest member
elected to Congress she speaks for a
huge number of people
she is the darling of the Democrat Party
they trot her out to fundraise she is
representing a lot of people and she
doesn't know anything
her head is entirely empty it is made of
air it is such a vacuum I'm surprised it
doesn't collapse in upon itself if you
were to fire a little ping pong ball in
there here's what you would hear maybe
it would fall out of here at some point
she doesn't know a thing and we have to
point this out or the infection the
disease of Socialists ignorant and envy
will spread like a poison how do I know
that she doesn't know anything here's
the latest nonsense that Ocasio Cortez
is spouting if we work our butts off to
make sure that we take back all three
chambers of Congress rabid all three
chambers of government the presidency
the Senate and the house in 2020 we
can't start working in 2020 all three
chambers of Congress all three chambers
of our bicameral legislature now you
might say there oh she just misspoke
Michael you missed speaks sometimes yeah
we all miss speak sometimes with Barack
Obama said there are 57 states in the
country nobody ever covered that they
don't every time George Bush sneezed
they would make him out to be a dunce
but Barack Obama says they're 57 states
okay zo Cortese says that there are
three chambers of our of our bicameral
legislature and nobody really talks
about it but she doubles down and she
still got it wrong she said no no I'm
sorry I mean the three chambers of
government you know the White House and
the House of Representatives and the
Senate those are not our three chambers
have got we don't have three chambers of
government we have three branches of
government and she still got those wrong
we have the executive branch that is the
White House that is the president we
have the legislative branch that is
bicameral it has the house in the Senate
and we have the judiciary the judicial
branch Supreme Court on top appellate
courts lot federal courts all these
courts three branches bicameral
legislature and a presidency
and a quart okay that's that's how our
government is set up dude does okay as
you of Cortez know that I'm skeptical
I'm skeptical that she knows that
look this cuts both ways sometimes
Donald Trump an excellent president he
once referred to bills that a judge
would sign was he miss speaking or has
he just not spent much time analyzing
the way that our government is set up I
assume it's the latter it's okay what is
the practical effect of that not very
much what is he doing in politics
excellent stuff so I'll let him off the
hook what does she want she wants to
spread the poison of socialism destroy
the greatest engine of prosperity and
peace and justice in the entire world
you don't let her get away with that you
don't let her get away with some stupid
comment because it's all charming until
she's running the government you know
it's all charming and funny and farcical
until President Ocasio Cortez is is
elected you know and were at the
inauguration I don't I don't know who
her vice president would be I'd maybe
debbie Wasserman Schultz and then you'd
have the occasional Cortez Wasserman
Schultz administration would be a real
mouthful that it's all funny until she's
got real power fortunately she doesn't
yet but she's trying to raise it she's
protesting Nancy Pelosi she's going into
her office she is clearly an ambitious
person and she's not intelligent and
she's not educated at whatsoever she's
not knowledgeable but she is shrewd you
don't get yourself elected president you
don't upend of many term incumbent if
you're not politically shrewd she is you
gotta watch her she's a snake in the
grass she's a fraud she's a liar
she pretends to be Jenny from the block
she's not she's from a ritzy suburb
she's from the richer town right next to
the town that I grew up in and you
really got a watcher and we don't want
to be mean to her but you can't let her
off the hook either
okay all right it's important with
melenik Malayalis don't know civics they
do not know set study after study shows
this the Millennials don't know anything
about civics they did a study they they
did a poll of a thousand people to see
who could name the five rights enshrined
in the First Amendment you know how many
people got all five of them one one out
of a thousand I a huge proportion of
them couldn't name any of the rights it
couldn't him free speech or a freedom of
religion or freedom of assembly
couldn't name any of those so this is a
big worry one-third of American
Millennials think George Bush killed
more people than Joseph Stalin did a I
think the majority of American
Millennials have never heard of the no
that's not true but a huge number of
American Millennials have never heard of
the Holocaust don't know what ouch Fitz
is really scary stuff you've got to
watch out when people are ignorant an
aspect that will cut both ways that
helps to educate people and but also
cuts away at our common cultural
education is a major news story that is
not really being covered TV is over
video killed the TV star videos like
this we're not on TV right now we're not
on linear TV we're on the Internet we're
on Facebook we're on YouTube maybe
you're watching us on a TV but it's cuz
you're streaming it from somewhere else
you're watching on daily wire TV is over
I obviously have a personal interest in
this I like the TV is over because it
means more people are watching this but
there's some pretty crazy political
lessons here in the third quarter of
2018 the largest number of people ever
cut their subscriptions to cable and
satellite television we have this has
been he asleep ends been going on for a
long time and analysts predicted it
would slow down it would stop and then
people people who have TV would just
maintain it that's not happening was the
largest number ever in the third quarter
cable and satellite companies lost more
than a million subscribers from July to
September why is this in part it's
because TV is very overpriced you're
paying $100 a month on average that's
the average cost of a cable subscription
to watch three channels you don't want
you get a million channels but nobody
watches a million channels you only
watched two or three really you won't
maybe you watch the news maybe you watch
sports and you can get sports for free
on Antenna TV but but the other reason
for this is choice you get choice how
many shows do i watch at any given time
maybe I watch two or three shows and I
and I listen to podcasts or I listen to
audiobooks or whatever I'm not sitting
there watching the primetime lineup on
NBC or something like that we want what
we want and we can get it through other
services this is a huge win for
conservatives more choice more freedom
this is an unqualified good for
conservatives the way that the left has
dominated our culture is
they force-fed us all of their tripe for
years and years and we've just had to
deal with it now conservatives have
their own platforms you know it's not
we're not in the giant sound stage over
in the Studio City or something but
we're getting huge numbers a huge
audience huge audiences of people who
want a message that they're not getting
who want information that they're not
getting from the left-wing media this is
an unqualified good for conservatives it
will further erode the common culture we
don't have a lot holding us together and
now we don't watch the same sitcoms I
think in part this is caused by greedy
corrupt hack Hollywood that turns out a
lot of trash that politicizes their
shows you know there have been there are
shows that have political message like
all in the family for instance had
obviously was a largely about politics
the conservative Archie Bunker character
against the left-wing meathead character
but it used politics at least to advance
the plot of the show now what Hollywood
does is uses this shows to advance their
politics to the detriment of the
entertainment this erosion of the common
culture is a big worry because we don't
have a single language in the United
States the Left doesn't want Spanish
speakers to learn English doesn't want
other immigrant groups to learn English
they don't want an official language
there's no common religious basis in the
u.s. anymore the fastest-growing group
is are the nuns they're religiously
unaffiliated it's people who are
spiritual but not religious it's not
that rock solid Christian culture that
the United States once had we are
increasingly polarized politically and
put greater portent importance into
politics largely because of the erosion
of religion and culture so we are we're
having that common culture ripped apart
this is accelerating it all I can say is
this is what freedom looks like this is
freedom safety sweet nice all together
common culture Leave It to Beaver which
never really existed by the way but that
idea that's nice but that's not freedom
that's not when you're free to say what
you want consume what you want explore
ideas that you want to that's not
freedom this is what freedom looks like
it's not as
nostalgic it'sit's not this thing that
we're nostalgic for in the 1940s and 50s
fair enough but nostalgia is history
after a few drinks as they say so I'm
skeptical that it ever happened this is
freedom conservatives should celebrate
it
cut the cord some more cut cut cut go
for it before we go I really have to
play this clip this was made by our own
Paul Cardinal Bois and Donovan Fowler
they came up with this you know you know
Paul Carden why he would come on the
show all the time if we still had the
panel he'd be coming on every day they
were looking at that megyn kelly
blackface saga megyn kelly suggested
that sometimes if he puts dark makeup on
it's not the end of the world
NBC summarily fired her here is a PSA
from Watt and Fowler on the fallout we
interrupt this program to deliver you a
special public service announcement from
NBC we at NBC care deeply about
diversity and racial sensitivity we were
appalled when megyn kelly recently
questioned whether it's okay to wear
black face or use dark makeup to
impersonate a black person and she made
her skin look darker than it really is
and people said that that was racist to
be clear it has never been okay for
someone to darken their skin to appear
black like Darrell Hammond did to play
Jesse Jackson on NBC in like Fred
Armisen did to play President Obama on
NBC and like Fred Armisen did to play
Prince on NBC and like Fred Armisen did
to play David Paterson on NBC and like
Jimmy Fallon did to play Chris Rock on
NBC and like Ted Danson did after
starring on cheers on NBC and before
starring in the good place on NBC and
like Rachel Dolezal did during an
interview on NBC
we at NBC wished to assure you that
megyn kelly has been fired because at
NBC you are not allowed to discuss
blackface you can only wear it
[Music]
the more you know get your questions in
for the conversation that's coming up
today and for the mailbag tomorrow and I
will see you what the conversations come
and I'll see you in like an hour
until then I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy bori senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you